ich möchte mich auf einen mann
konzentrieren von dem ich glaube dass er
gemobbt wird karl lauterbach der mann
der wie kein anderer in dieser pandemie
über corona gesprochen hat der experte
für das fach der immer gewarnt gemahnt
häufig recht manchmal auch nicht so ganz
recht hatte aber definitiv eins ist klar
erst ein experte und was passiert jetzt
die spd so scheint es die will ihm das
gesundheitsministerium nicht geben das
könnte man ihm nicht und man hört hinter
den rhein dass man lästert über karl
lauterbach in der spd der zu viel im
fernsehen der hat sich dann in den
ganzen sendungen den vbk ein ministerium
zu so hört man das aus der spd für mich
ist das echtes mobbing für einen mann
der ist verdient hätte jetzt endlich
gesundheitsminister zu werden so viele
jahre hat es versucht ist es da nie
geworden und jetzt in dieser
entscheidenden phase der pandemie sage
ich karl lauterbach muss an der paul in
deiner rolle als bild für sie kann ich
das natürlich verstehen ich meine der
eine oder andere lacher denn würde er
schon geben schlagzeilen wurde er machen
wir hätten immer viel zu schreiben aber
ich muss sagen ich frage mich warum
sollte er den gesundheitsminister werden
weil ich am besten dann würde ich mit
dir dementieren er ist fachlich am
besten die einst würde sagen auch von
einem biologen ist lauterbach der auf
denen sollten wir heute mich hier
gegenüberstand flimm peter lauterbach zu
gescheiter neben den falschen prognosen
konfrontiert ist ja nicht so dass alle
anderen immer alles richtig gemacht
haben ich finde karl lauterbach als
jemand der das immer wieder dann
eingeordnet hat auch klargestellt hat
der gesagt hat ich beziehe mich auf neue
wissenschaftliche studien ich habe
gestern nach wieder was gelesen inhaber
da kam wieder eine studie über und dann
hat carlotta war sich verbessert zum
beispiel bei allen corona team muss man
sagen und er ist dran geblieben ich
glaube er wäre jetzt ein paar gewesen
doch ganz klar sehen was für ein los für
die gesellschaft auch dank seiner
prognose entstanden ist also es hat ja
wirklich uns auch freiheiten kostet die
gar nicht hätten sein müssen immer und
ich finde jemand der immer nur sendet ja
er der schon viel gesehen ich meine war
der keiner so oft bei lanz wie er und
ich finde er hätte auch einfach mal
sagen müssen ich kann es gar nicht
beurteilen weil das ist doch die
wahrheit die ganzen gesundheitsexperte
und dazu auch karl lauterbach die
wussten ja meistens selber nichts weil
man diese partie auch nicht einschätzen
kann und er setzt plötzlich der große
held mit den ganzen falschen prognosen
also für mich wäre es das schlimmste
wenn karl lauterbach gesundheitsminister
the pauls sie komme aus köln am dort
jemals oder haben dort die kleine stadt
anzeiger geleitet sind jetzt chef des
kölner presse clubs wie erleben sie karl
lauterbach dort karl lauterbach ist eine
feste größe karl lauterbach hat immer
etwas zu sagen und wenn eine kamera und
ein mikrofon da sind auch ich habe ihnen
immer in jeder debatte als bereicherung
empfunden nur frage ich mich wer
wirklich ein guter gesundheitsminister
bringt er die erforderlichen
eigenschaften mit ist er bereit sich so
einer disziplin zu unterwerfen die man
als minister haben muss oder ist es für
ihn nicht auch besser wenn er der freier
vogel ist der dann auch mal etwas raus
haut und sich dann sechs stunden später
korrigieren muss also ich frage mich tun
hat im land einen gefallen und tun wir
karl lauterbach einen gefallen damit
seine verdienste in allen ehren aber er
ist so schwer führbar wie ein kleines
modell auto oder dass der kanal in eurem
alter waren werden
der entspannt war ein guter
gesundheitsminister als auch schwer
gehabt und da ist natürlich klar für den
der amtiert in so einer krise der kriegt
natürlich auch alle negative aspekte
dann mit aber zum karl lauterbach ich
habe es hier in der runde ja schon mal
gesagt der fällt ja in den medien immer
als gesundheitsexperte auf dem bundestag
hat die spd bundestagsfraktion ihr sogar
aus dem gesundheitsausschuss abgezogen
der ist ja jetzt im rechtsausschuss
jurist ist ein richtig glaubt im
gesundheitsausschuss weder praktisch
noch nicht da und so naja ich bin im
innenausschuss im rechtsausschuss habe
ich ihn ab und angesehen wortbeitrag
habe ich da von ihm werfen voll noch nie
gehört aber spaß beiseite ich glaube
sein sein sein hauptproblem ist
wahrscheinlich aber eher und wenn man
das so beobachtet dann scheint ja
proporz auch eine riesenrolle zu spielen
wenn man die athletik würde bei ihm nie
der fall sein danach konnten
im kern ist der proporz für karl
lauterbach glaube ich so aus der
innenperspektive von meiner partei schon
auch ein problem so wäre es bei mir auch
ich meine er ist keine frau und er kommt
aus dem falschen landesverband und ich
glaube das wird dann in der logik der
olaf scholz da bei der postenbesetzung
folgt ein problem das ist ein wichtiger
punkt aber wir sollten nicht verhehlen
nina dass karl lauterbach immer
derjenige weiter zumindest eine linie
hatte und die linie war zu warnen er
intensiv vor den folgen von corona
aufgestellt oder eine kerze mit melzer
in verschiedenen talkshows natürlich
hast du recht bilanz hat sich aber auch
hier gestellt mehrfach immer wieder ist
ein was ich in den zweiten sonntag hat
ja auch aufrütteln wollen die
bevölkerung und wie wir jetzt sehen
offenbar zu recht das müssen wir alle
eingestehen also alle gesagt haben dass
man gut sein corona ist vorbei da hat er
gesagt ist noch lang nicht links nicht
vorbei ich teile aber ihre meinung nicht
dass das hast du ja oft auch
noch einen punkt zu ihrem punkt kann er
sein ministerium führen karl lauterbach
in allen ehren ich glaube das auch nicht
weil dazu ist er zu sehr freigeist ein
solches ministerium braucht jemand der
auch die administration führen kann so
ein gesundheitsministerium ist ein
schwer zu führendes haus und da braucht
es jemand der administrative erfahrungen
ich glaube aber das ist eine
herausgehobene post brauche karl
lauterbach vielleicht gibt es den sogar
es wird ja so ein corona expertengremium
der bundesregierung geht und ich glaube
die sowohl auf schaut dann sagte dass
lauterbach mit all seiner expertise das
wird führen können die psychische
gesundheit zb auch ein ganz großer fahrt
den sollte auch ein gesundheitsminister
bedenken und ich muss ehrlich gesagt
sagen karl lauterbach hat sich für die
psychische gesundheit unserer
gesellschaft überhaupt nicht
interessiert da muss ich sagen man hat
also ehrlich gesagt auch eigentlich
sparen der sagt freunde lasst euch im
pflaster ostern auf den letzten drücker
aber beyoncé kriegt er nicht wissen die
ganze gesellschaft piontek bild
erfreulich aber was das tut mit der
psyche der menschen muss man sagen ich
bin da auch nicht mehr findet das ein
guter gesundheit war ich finde nur auf
ihren sparen wurde so eingedeutscht sich
jetzt nicht mehr von
manchen ja ja
der einstige minister der andere ist
gesundheitsexperte da gibt es ja doch
einen unterschied im übrigen ist der
andere immer noch im amt also das sollte
man nicht hinten anstellen wenn du über
psyche der menschen rede ist dann frage
ich mich was das mit der psyche macht
all das was der in den letzten wochen
verbockt hat wenn wir so sache wer so
den königsweg den ein
gesundheitsminister in einer solchen
situation gehen kann den haben wir
glaube ich alle noch nicht ausgemacht
und es wird keinen geben dem der
beispiellose zufliegt wie haben sie das
heute alles um den tatort nach leichter
dann als die des machens das ist glaube
ich auch so wie wir haben sie das
wahrgenommen heute olaf scholz auftritt
der nicht gesagt hat gesundheitsminister
werden soll weil bei der spd die
ministerposten offiziell erst am vierten
dezember glaube ich verteilt werden aber
er hat sich zu corona geäußert man hatte
das gefühl
viel gesagt aber wird jetzt ein
krisenstab eingerichtet aber was neues
kann man nicht oder nein kam nichts
neues und wir kommen ja zu einer
späteren stunde auch noch zu diesem
punkt
zurzeit sind wir da in so einer art
niemandsland finde ich das ist
erschreckend die eine regierung geht und
sie ist träger und die andere
beschäftigt sich mit der zukunft und man
fragt sich ob das nun alles ist was sie
für die gegenwart haben mit diät morgen
wachen wir auf mit neuen man kann es
sagen horrorzahlen wissen das auch
natürlich die ängste bei den infizierten
sehen dabei 70.000 ist natürlich schon
eine nummer wohl sagen ui da fragt sich
jeder was wird denn daraus werden in
zwei wochen und das so auszuklammern das
thema eigentlich auch nicht den
horrorzahlen stadt nicht persönlich aber
als bürgerin ganz stark schon immer die
hospitalisierung rate und dann steht da
die dance aber es nie ich finde es viel
besser wir sagen so und soviel betten
sind belegt von komapatienten so viel
prozent sind frei wenn man sich das
wirklich ankommt bekommt ein nicht so
ein horror wie wenn man immer diese
schlagzeilen sieht ich finde dass wir
mit der panikmache in diesem land
wirklich auffallen müssen ich finde dass
die ab heute nochmal die zahl
nachgeschaut zum beispiel da kommt spät
aber mehr häusliche gewalt im lockdown
da gibt es auch neue zahlen zu bezahlen
während der kubakrise ein riesen preis
und eine pandemie ist fürchterlich sie
schrecklich sie kostet wir müssen darauf
nicht bei durch aber ich finde und das
finde ich auch bei einem
gesundheitsminister ist weg ich bin
gegen carlo aber man muss doch als
minister auch hinterfragen wir haben eh
ein los wir werden verlieren weil dieser
pandemie aber um den schutz des lebens
zu wahren träume von jungen menschen
zerstören höher ist häusliche gewalt
zuzulassen ich frage mich manchmal ob
wir in deutschland nicht langsamer sagen
müssen okay wir müssen langsam
entscheidungen treffen aber nicht alles
zu lasten der jungen leute was wäre dann
deine richtung sozusagen also wenn du
jetzt entscheiden könnte ist du wirst
wenn ich ein sprachunterricht im
ersteren jetzt oder müsste es dort
mitreden in expertengremien was sollte
deutschland tun ich hätte von anfang an
die great basin declaration verfolgt und
ich hätte vor allem den schutz auf die
älteren gruppen gelegt ich bin der
überzeugung zum beispiel wenn man 70
jahre alt ist ich kenne zum beispiel 70
jährige die eine sehr große angst vor
krone das kann ich auch verstehen
diese bleiben zu hause sein alltag
komplett alleine menschen wieder zu
hause ja die machen das selbst sein anna
der durchgängig aber ich glaube wir
müssen halt schon in der gesellschaft
auch mal darüber debattieren was sind
die psychologischen folgen wie hoch ist
die dunkelziffer bei gewaltopfern also
mich hat jetzt wirklich erschrocken im
vergleich zum vorjahr stieg die zahl der
gewaltopfer in partnerschaften und 4,4
prozent an wo merkt man wenn es kinder
nicht gut geht in der schule und ich
finde dass ein gesundheitsminister das
auch auf dem schirm haben muss das ist
das haus brett und die daraus lernen
außer mir will niemand karl lauterbach
als minister ich sage nochmal falls olaf
scholz hier zu hören karl lauterbach
oder minister werden